بابا جاب لي هديه سياره لمجسم سياره صغير
850 فهي هاي السياره اللي خلتني ادخل في
الموضوع اكثر صار عندي اهتمام افهم ليش
هيك شكلها كان عمري 16 سنه لما فرطت اول
ماتور كان دايما الهوس انزل على البيادر
بعمان
بالكراجات بس مشان الله دخلوني
شوي شوي لاعبين ما كانت الجامعه الالمانيه
بدها تفتح جديد
وكنت رايحه على موضوع الميكاترونكس لانه
هو كان
رحت على القسم وكان الشخص المناسب بالمكان
المناسب اعطاني الكيورد اللي هي اوتوموتيف
ديزاين من هون بلش انه اوكي في شيء اسمه
اندستريال ديزاين في اشي اسمه برودكت
ديزاين في اشي اسمه
[موسيقى]
عليهم كلهم كان عندي منهم قبول ما حدا كان
يقادر يساعدني لاني احمل الجواز السفر
الاردني نوت ما عم بحكيها بطريقه بس دائما
الدعم عم بيكون لجهات معينه او بسبب قضايا
معينه
ولا مره انطبقت علي هاي الشروط
بالاخر قررت انه اشتغل شوي على حالي اجمع
مصاري واخد جزئيه اللي هي ممكن تصلح لالي
واكمل هنا اجا دور اهلي انه هم كانوا
الدعم
بهذا الموضوع انه اطلعي كملي شوفي انت وين
شايفه حالك احنا مامنين فيك اكتر ما انت
مامنه في حالك رده فعل المجتمع لما
حكيت انه انا بدي ادخل في مجال السيارات
كان دائما بضحك انه ايش السيارات اه اوكي
يضحك
فيها شوي من الاستهزاء وبنفس الوقت انه اه
ان شاء الله اذا بطلع في ايدك فما حدا كان
ياخذني
بجديه لما احكي عن موضوع
بس
التحدي الحقيقي اللي كان يصير لما يكون في
صناع قرار لما يكون بدي انتقل من من مرحله
لثانيه زي السكولر شيبس زي التطور بالسلم
الوظيفي زي استلام مشروع هنا ببين المعدن
الحقيقي
دائما كان في انه اه اوكي انت بنت بدك حدا
يساعدك او اذا احنا بدنا ندفع عليك هالقد
قديش عمرك انت ممكن تتزوجي في اخرتك تضلي
بالبيت فانا ليش استثمر فيك هدول الاشياء
كلهم سمعتهم
بس عمرها ما اثرت في
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اللي قدرت اعمله انه اخلق مبادره اسمها
تمكين المراه في مجال السيارات فعباره عن
مساحه من خلال شبكه من الشركات اللي هم
بيشتغلوا في مجال صناعه وصيانه السيارات
انه احنا بنقدر نشبك هدول البنات اللي
عندهم فاشن اللي عندهم شغف نقدر نطور
المهارات الموجوده عندهم اما من خلال
تدريب او اعطائهم كورسات او توجيههم
للطريقه الصحيح وبنفس الوقت من خلال شبكه
من الشركات اللي بتتعامل معنا احنا بنقدر
نخلق لها فرصه عمل
[موسيقى]
الشركه هاي اكيد بدها تكون من
بالعالم بتصميم السيارات
برضو وحده من الاهداف اللي عم نشتغل عليها
انه يتم تمييز المكتب عالميا في مجال
تصميم السيارات يكون في النا سياره فعليا
تاثر على المجتمع بطريقه ايجابيه
ويكون في قادرين نكسر الحاجز وفكره انه
بنات بتصميم السيارات والتصميم الخارجي
وكيف ديزاينر يبطل اشي
يصير اشي موجود عادي
لانه التصميم هو فاشن والتصميم هو مهاره
وموهبه فما الها دخل بشب او بنت اذا الشاب
هو شاطر ومستحق هاي الفرصه لتتبيه وبرضه
اذا البنت شاطره وتستحق هاي الفرصه برضو
تاخذ حقها فه
وهذا الاشي الشغاله عليه